You've just implemented a program that shows two kinds of question; a plain
question and a numeric question. Both of them work past to the presentQuestion
method. Clearly we can extend the system with all sorts of other question
types, and we won't ever have to change the presentQuestion method. So, what
polymorphism gives us is extensible software systems. We can start out with
something simple and without having to change any of the basic structure. We
can extend the functionality by adding more and more subclasses. Polymorphism
is one of the two corner stones of object orientated programming. The other one
is encapsulation. Remember that encapsulation means, we separate the interface
of a class from it's implementation. And that means that the implementations
can evolve over time and gain more functionality without having to change the
rest of the system. So, both of these cornerstone properties let us build
systems that start out small and that can be functional for a long time. Which
is why object-oriented programming has become such a popular methodology for
writing programs. Now, in a few short weeks, you have gone from just becoming
familiar with objects and how they work, to being able to write quite
sophisticated programs that can withstand the test of time. So, you've really
come a long way in this introduction to programming, and I hope you enjoyed it.